de par les interpellés par les policiers
finansol je pose aucune résistance
je me laisse faire il doit directement
ça commence les insultes et moi on va nu
pieds je vais tout est amer et c'était
vraiment réduction mois sur mais moi je
me laisse faire violer aucune résistance
à ce moment-là fini dans le véhicule de
police qui a accidenté je n'étais je pas
assez dans sur la banquette arrière
ces religieux ou non la sanction de
sécurité français laurent sato mis à
part les insultes joli kivu menottes
si vous avez fait un délit de fuite je
pense nicolas pernikoff césaire c'est
normal mais c'est vrai que les insultes
mais voilà ça c'est vrai il ya eu des
insultes à caractère raciste ont triplé
de farah à plusieurs reprises en fait
quand charme dans le véhicule de police
tant mieux le premier policier procédait
à un contrôle évitent ce que j'ai dans
les pages il prend ma carte d'identité
il voyait directement qu'il fait issus
de banlieues qui j'ai des origines
arabes et delà des insultes à caractère
raciste et x à la suite c'est sale arabe
et a rien à faire en france on rentre
chez toi alors qu'ils allaient ma carte
d'identité française dakar et à ce
moment là j'ai appris c'est qu'il
montait dans le coffre
c'est le dernier véhicule et 5008 il ya
un policer sont à gauche est la police
et qui ont été dans le coffre
à ce moment là le policier qui se remet
à gauche m'insulte à répétition mais
j'ai préparé j'ai fait pas attention
d'accord lpj c'est quelqu'un entre dans
le coffre il était monté dans le coffre
pour m'étrangler
c'est à dire dans les cinq minutes ils
seront ils sont vraiment grand
le 4 est vraiment grande policier maître
anglais il geeks va mourir tu es mort
témoin le policier qui était sur ma
gauche il a directement commencé à
vaciller plusieurs coups de poing au
niveau de l'abdomen et ça s'est répété à
quatre ou cinq reprises les mois ce
nombre à genoux jim et mahdia s'arrête
là c'est fini pour moi je vais mourir
j'ai suivi leur place à georges frêche
je me dis en fait là si je peux mourir
d'instruction aujourd'hui choqués à
faire également cédric joue bien
voilà se livrèrent sur moment de la
fouille que les choses les choses vont
aller encore plus loin
vous enlevez vos vêtements commencent à
arriver au commissariat j'arrive au
confort et à 100 mais en sol des
fouilles à corps avec elle dès demain
policiers les deux mêmes policiers qui
l'ont interpellé
je suis toujours avec eux et moi ce
moment là j'enlève ma ds mon petit chat
entretien avec policy qui rentre et j'ai
policier brij lal est ce qu'on va faire
l'afrique chine mettra ne mettrai pas de
soucis vous faire ma porte
j'enlève mon pantalon et chaussures au
moment du talent st ledger policiers
craint en disant que j'allais vers
l'action les policiers me demande quelle
alimentation g200 caleçon et à ce moment
là junte de police et il j'ai pour toi
accroupis toi et tous ce qui est
formellement interdit
à ce moment là je prenais police est il
pas atteint ce matin j'ai envie d'une
gifle sur une première fois
j'écoute et je suis sûr nous reposions
deux enfants lily chaussures et à ce
moment là à ce moment là j'ai un
policier qui se jette sur moi qui le
trouvent notamment à ce moment là j'ai
besoin pour se dire qu'ils sont au
niveau 2 les gens lehtinen des guides
pratiques été vraiment violent
j'avais la respiration coupée j'avais le
souffle coupé gt en caleçon je recevais
des coups bas
j'étais tremblay à ce moment là j'ai
pour cette fiction tels sont les temps
sont qualifiés qu'elles sont introduits
dans trop d'endroits dans mon auto
le battu parce que c'était vraiment une
sensation bizarre j'étais petit je n'ai
pas jack effel
il s'est arrêté d'être j'en pouvais plus
de plus dépassé tout pour que ça se
passe bien
j'ai été violée j'ai été tabassé je n'en
pouvais plus écrire il ya personne qui
intervenait à ce moment là chut au sol
et un policier qui sort son téléphone
mais qu'une photographie
il prend en photo avec son téléphone
alors que j'étais
et puis ça génial quand elle j'ai fait
tout ça depuis depuis seulement qui
court après un policier pour qui
manquait à ce moment là je suis traîné
suite ce n'est pas que l'autre il est
l'auteur la salle d'accueil entre-temps
j'ai manqué mon caleçon
mais de l'aveu de cette somme doit
s'assurer fini ce qu'ils veulent
voilà gîte au sol en accueil j'avais la
main droite pour l'hôtel quand je te
laisse à m